in this video you're gonna learn how to
write recursive formulas for arithmetic
sequences geometric sequences as well as
something don't fall into either of
those categories so we're going to go
through three examples and I'm going to
show you two different methods to write
these recursive formulas your teacher
may show you a slightly different way so
I want to show you a couple different
methods to hopefully help you understand
this little bit better so for number one
what's the pattern here we're going from
18 to 14 to 10 to 6 to 2 dot dot dot how
are we getting to the next term in this
sequence or in this list of numbers well
if you said that you're subtracting 4
each time you're absolutely right so
when you write a recursive formula what
you want to do is you want to tell the
person what the first term is so a sub 1
equals 18 and then you want to give them
like rule or like a you know an
indication of how do you get to that
next term so one thing I want to show
you really quick is see this notation N
equals 1 N equals 2 N equals 3 that
tells you what term that you're on
whereas C 18 right here this is like a
sub 1 or 14 this is a sub 2 the sub just
means like subscript like it's a little
bit lower like a little bit below the
line and so that tells you what's the
value of that third term oh it's 10
what's the value of that fourth term
it's 6 but n is really just like what
term you're on so now we've got the
value of our first term is 18 but to get
to the nth term the value of the nth
term what we're going to do is we're
going to take the previous term see n
minus 1 and we're going to subtract 4
and this is when n is greater than or
equal to 2 meaning for the second term
third term fourth term in and so on so
let's test it out for this as N equals 3
N equals 4 N equals 5 let's say we
wanted to figure out what N equals 6 is
so a sub 6 ok so n is 6 that's going to
be 6 minus 1 that's a sub 5 that's the
value of this fifth term we're gonna
then subtract 4 which gives us negative
2 but another way to think about it is
when you see this n minus 1 right here
this n minus 1 tells you to go one term
back like one previous term and then you
subtract four and that's how you get to
the next term once you see the pattern
you can just keep subtracting four
subtracting four to get you know a
number of terms in a row so this is one
method the other method that sometimes
is used is like this they'll say a sub
one is equal to 18 so that's the value
of the first term we need some starting
point but then how do we get to the next
term well here we did a sub N and this
one I'm going to do a sub n plus one so
that's like you know one term beyond the
nth term so you're going to take
whatever the nth term is a sub n that
value and you're gonna subtract four but
now I'm going to say when n is greater
than or equal to one okay so basically
this is like if you were to put one in
here one plus one is two okay so you're
finding the value of the second term but
remember how we said N equals one so you
take the value of that first term and
you subtract four if you wanted to find
the sixth term in order for this to be
six and it would have to be five right 5
plus 1 is 6 so a sub 5 that's the value
of the fifth term we subtract 4 and you
get the the next term
so either method whichever one you
prefer will work let's do another
example see you like for number two here
what's the pattern how are we going from
125 to 25 to 5 to 1 to 1/5 what are we
doing to get to that next term well if
you said dividing by 5 you're right but
dividing by 5 is like multiplying by the
reciprocal 1/5 right so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go ahead and start
just like we did with this one we're
gonna say a sub 1 equals the first term
the value of the first term 125 but to
get to the value of the nth term we're
going to take the N minus 1 term
remember that's the previous term and
we're going to multiply by 1/5 and
that's when n is greater than equal to 2
meaning when you're on the second term
third term fourth term of course a sub
one we already know the value of the
first term so that's one option the
other option is a sub 1 equals 125 and
then a sub n plus one equals a sub n
times 1/5 and this would be when n is
greater than or equal to 1 so either way
you can either think of like n plus 1
that's like one term you know beyond the
nth term like one term additional you
just take the value of the term that
you're on that nth term and you're
multiplied by one-fifth that's one way
this way is what I learned originally
and so I kind of stuck with it a little
bit more I just like to think of
whenever I see n minus 1 I think about
oh I just go back one term so if I
wanted to find this term here I just go
back one term and I multiply by 1/5 and
that's gonna make this one 25th and you
can keep repeating that pattern okay
number three is kind of a little bit
more challenging so see if you can
follow this one with me see if you can
see the pattern here what are we doing
to get to the next term next term next
term well here it kind of looks like
we're subtracting eight but then here it
looks like we're adding one so it
doesn't look like it's consistent as far
as adding or subtracting the same thing
how about multiplying or dividing no
there must be some other pattern right
well see if you can follow this pattern
it looks like 15 minus 7 that's 8 7
minus 8 that's negative 1 8 minus a
negative 1 that's 9 so you see what's
happening here the first term we know is
15 the second term we know is 7 but to
get to the nth term okay let's say for
example this one here we're gonna go to
back so it's a sub n minus 2 and we're
gonna subtract the 1 that's just one
before it and minus 1 and that's going
to be 4 and greater than or equal to 3
meaning like for the third term and
beyond so again remember that n minus 2
that means whatever term you want to
find like say for example if I wanted to
find this one right here I'd have to go
to back and then to find and then I'd
have to take the one that's 1 back the n
minus 1 and then I would subtract so
that's one option the other option is
again we could say a 1 equals 15 a sub 2
equals 7 that's a this is the second
term and then we could say a sub n plus
2 equals a sub n - a sub n plus
one and that's going to be what when n
is greater than or equal to 2 to 1 so 1
plus 2 would be 3 this would be defined
the third term so what we're doing is
we're taking so when n equals let's say
1 to find the third term you're taking
the first term which is 15 minus 1 plus
1 which is the second term that's 7 15
minus 7 equals 8 which is the third term
if you want to see more about sequences
in series working with explicit formulas
recursive formulas the formulas for
finding the sum etc follow me over to my
sequences in series review video right
there I'll see you in that video